how would I come back to this idea
that's really thematic in the film that
is love kind of renders you mute that
love doesn't require a language your
characters don't speak but they
communicate love in ways that are not
bound by dialogue with that your central
idea from the very beginning that idea
and how to tell that story without
dialogue know the first thing wants to
come in not through the front door with
the alpha males but to come through the
service entrance with invisible and
silent people nameless people the
Russian spy that can reduce his name
somebody would have boys people that are
invisible to to the guy that in 1954
would be the hero of the movie the guy
full of certainty becomes the villain
and what was very clear when
articulating the screenplay sigh is that
everybody that had the power of speech
all the characters all of them have huge
problems communicating and the ones that
don't speak because silence is very
precise they communicate beautifully you
know and and it was needed to be that
because the purity of the of them I
think that love is recognition and and
recognizing the other Ness and falling
in love with the other nests and and the
at the same time you recognize essence
from yourself and when I was working
with Sally I gave her a little box of
blu-rays with her Lloyd Buster Keaton
Charlie Chaplin and more importantly I
said Stan Laurel I said Stan Laurel can
do everything without doing anything
study him and she did and she really
based very seriously a lot of her energy
the state of grace of Stan Laurel Doug
what was what was Jer Mo's pitch to you
to remember what he said to you when he
first approached you about this movie oh
do I we were working on crimson peak at
the time and I had a I played to his
ghost ladies than that and the long
story but I but I had a day off and he
called me into his office during lunch
time that day and and said close the
door and he had a quiet talk with me no
script to read for me yet but verbally
he told me
this tale of a fish man who's been
acquired from the Amazon and and I'm
like okay so that makes sense
you know it's Guillermo and I the guy
who plays his creatures sure this is all
makes sense so far
and then came the gravity of the moment
when he said and and duggie I want you
to be you're going to be the romantic
leading male of this movie now that's
hard for me to picture anyway but in a
fish suit even more so yeah so so
finding that but let love story on film
and and and and approaching this not
from not from a physical performance
aspect but but approaching it from an
enacting place where I find her heart
and soul she finds mine we communicate
and like you said without one word
spoken so Sally Hawkins Sally Hawkins
right I when you are communicating
non-verbally with someone you hope that
it's Sally Hawkins because yeah she is a
brilliant angel from heaven and she
wears her heart out here and and it was
so easy to communicate with her we had
dance rehearsal time alright little
dance number which I loved and during
that three weeks of rehearsal it was
most glorious what was your big problem
to solve in terms of story how did you
guys what were the conversations
arguments debates that you had as
collaborators well I I sort of feel like
the problems to solve were mainly simply
the structural underpinnings of how it
all worked with sort of the plot because
I think that you know the love story was
there and the visuals were all there and
the thematics were there and so it was
really just a matter of putting the
puzzle pieces together sort of what was
interesting as a lot of people think
that the gender a cliche and think that
Vanessa came in and did the romantic
stuff and I did the hardcore stuff it
was the opposite she wanted she gave you
the violence and you were through the
love story she was she was one of the
things is we met and
and you know I have about 20-something
pages and the rest in beat sheet and
listen net and and and she said you're
missing a whole element and she said can
we expand on the story of the Russians
and can we expand on the general which
are dimensionally important and we we
started at that and what we did is we
took turns this is the way I'd like to
collaborate is we have meetings
preferably over food you know a good
sushi restaurant has never heard in a
fish movie and and we met in a sushi
restaurant the first that and and then
what I would say is I will do my things
I would give it to her and say do
whatever you want
destroy erase have and then when it
comes to me come to the same and then we
would see what each removed I would say
why did you take out or she would say
why did you take out this and and we
that's one of the conversations were
integrant 1-1 you had it it was yours
miles there's a way in which this movie
the budget of this movie can become the
aesthetic but the budget of this movie
was not the aesthetic because this was a
movie that was shot for less than twenty
million dollars so what does that mean
nineteen point three so what does that
mean in terms of production department
heads locations to pull off a movie that
looks like this for that amount of money
wait two hundred thousand under budget
sir you gave well yet the original
budget when people say tell us the truth
because the original budget and the
budget that is published in nineteen
point five they say it's not nineteen
point five I know it is and it's 19.3
fine sounds matter but we actually ended
up as of one four weeks ago we were we
we gave change back to Fox Searchlight
two hundred thousand dollars back well
well you know Guillermo likes to say
budget is a state of mind which
originally I thought okay that's kind of
rhetorical [ __ ] but it's actually
true I thought he was playing me
but really you know it's we had to be
resourceful and it's an ambitious movie
as anyone can see so you know when
Guillermo came to me with it we talked
about how we could do it and we were
shooting the TV show at the time the
strain that we did together and I
thought okay well why don't we do it you
know Guillermo is a big Hitchcock fan
wrote a book knows all the movies could
talk here for hours and days about any
Hitchcock movie I said we're the same
time same fan says I said this can be
your psycho and we'll do it in between
seasons of the show you know with the
crew and using the stages and you know
the show was with Fox and this was with
Fox so we got really pretty resourceful
about it and we leaned on you know a
number of our people and you know it
worked out well that way but you know he
was very good you know we you know came
to realize that you know there was no
getting around the period and so we
embraced that and I felt like you know
there weren't so much compromises as
really kind of hard-won decisions that
that everybody made so and he was great
in that and so everyone had their oars
in the water and we it didn't feel like
we were ever really compromising you
know the thing that we did is from the
beginning we knew where we could cut
that didn't show on the screen is an
incredibly staged driven movie many many
sets but I mean we did simple stuff like
reuse extras so we have to only go
makeup on here and repeat those extras
from the street on the lab lalala you
could repeat the pants the shirt put a
lab coat then things like that reuse
sets for example Giles this apartment
wery dressed as Octavius house we put on
an extra window we put a little door
blah blah blah and and very important in
when we were planning I said I want to
use one of the oldest techniques that
comes from theater to shoot the opening
and the closing we're gonna use dry for
wet we will not do it in a pool so we
shot the opening and the closing of the
movie that needed complete control
we're shot in a stage with smoke and
snow
without a single drop of water so Dan
when you're working at a gear mo movie
you know you're not gonna pack a tripod
that's correct and not bring that along
but what is the look and feel of the
conversation what was the conversation
with the look and feel the show
and especially shooting those opening
closing sequences dry for web first time
I heard about this movie was when he was
doing the crimson peak and you know he
said to me we're going to do this movie
about a girl that cannot speak and a
fish man and we're going to shoot in
black and white and I said yes because
all cinematographers in the world wants
us you're black and white and then after
a while you know oh it's going to be
cholera and that was of course fantastic
because it looks pretty cool but the
first time I heard about it was in black
and white and you know came on me like
this moving a camera a lot you know
synchronized lighting soldiers and
cameras are very particularly about the
colors and where the camera is going to
be and that's going to be a big it's a
huge help for for me as a
cinematographer because you know exactly
where he's going to end and start in the
next shot so that's that's a big peak
hello Octavia I'm gonna come back to
something that Guillermo said at the
very beginning and that is the people
that are the biggest agents of change
are people who are either invisible or
ostracized you're black woman a closeted
gay man am you cleaning woman how
important is it that and we should
mention Richard Jenkins as Giles that
Richard Jenkins as Giles Octavia Zelda
and Sally it's Eliza are the people who
nobody sees but they're the people who
really see what is happening I think
that is a testament to Guillermo being a
multinational and and Mexican American
Canadian and a person who has been
characterized as the other so in order
to write and illuminate the plight of
those people you have to have a person
who you know basically has earned his
stripes and I think to utilize
marginalized
people to tell a story of this magnitude
not only allows us to be a little
introspective and how we treat one
another
that's just great story and and you know
I'm I'm grateful that he saw value of my
work and thought that I could you know
elevate Zelda so I'm grateful to have
been a voice for Eliza in some way Doug
if we were to visit you were working
with Sally what are the conversations
you have with Guillermo about
performance and about acting what are
the conversations that you have back
about what you can and cannot do and how
you're going to communicate your scenes
well because we've done so many films
together over 20 years you know this is
my sixth actually feature film with him
including Pan's Labyrinth I was the faun
on the pale man and that right now hey
thank you so he knew he knows me as a
very physical performer and he said I
don't want to dougie Jones performance
and did this with his hands like okay so
so this really did need to be a a soul
to soul connection took finding his his
regal Ness he was referred to my
character is referred to as a god right
in the locals in the Amazon where I was
found worshipped me as a God so even
though I was being beaten down and being
you know being biopsied and slowly
slowly losing my health and getting
weaker
I had to still carry myself in a way
that had regal warrant for that worship
from the Amazon so that was that was the
dichotomy I had to play in there and and
the communicating was Sally you know um
she was she was like a breath of fresh
air she was like the kind of the Savior
in that moment that she's that was my
salvation from that laboratory and I'd
ended but the turn of that you know at
the end when I do finally stand up after
and wipe off my own gunshot wounds and
and and it's like oh my gosh it was true
you know and then I I just I that those
moments were so so incredibly lovely to
play with her especially
see this strong woman and now now so we
took turns taking care of each other
right to the right to the end where
we're floating together side by side and
neither one of us is really in charge of
that moment it was just kind of beside
of my side taking care of each other for
all eternity now I just I couldn't
imagine anything more beautiful and I
would an honor to play all that oh thank
you for bringing us this movie and thank
you guys for coming